hey you guys time once again for my
flickers of fear show
and this movie what actually happened
with this one is that if you're a patron
i usually put a poll of like five
different movies that you can vote on
for the movie retrospective that tom and
i discuss uh that we put up on fridays
now i had put this movie in the poll and
it actually tied with another movie uh
roger corman's galaxy of terror and so i
decided rather than you know trying to
break the tie or whatever that tom and i
would do galaxy of terror because tom
really digs that movie and that i would
just do gothic which is what we're doing
today i don't know i
think probably tom has seen this one but
i'm not really sure if he'd be super
talented because this movie
okay so i saw this movie it came out in
1986
and it was directed by ken russell so
that should kind of tell you a lot right
there uh obviously most people that know
anything about film know who ken russell
is he obviously altered states the
devils uh we've also done we've done
altered states i think on movie
retrospective and we've done lair of the
white worm i think that might be the
only ken russell we've done we should
get around to doing the devils because i
really like that movie but he has a very
very specific style and it is all over
this movie now i saw this movie probably
like a bunch of times in the early 90s
like late 80s early 90s i feel like it
was on cable or something and because
i'm really into like old gothic
literature and i was really into like
mary shelley and everything so this was
right up my alley and it was i think i
taped it like on vhs off of cable and
watched it a bunch of times in the 1990s
and really really dug it but i don't
think i'd seen it since then but i had
been wanting to revisit it and then i
saw that it was on to be
so i decided to watch it and i had
forgotten
how
what's the word that i want to use for
this how like over the top like
hysterical this movie is not hysterical
like funny but hysterical like in the
sense of actual hysteria like every like
it seems like the whole movie is just
like people running around screaming and
crying and like overreacting to
everything and that's totally done on
purpose uh this is a very manic movie uh
it's a very trippy movie like most of
ken russell movies are i kind of feel
like he's even come forward and said
that he deliberately made this a little
bit as a black comedy uh which will be
apparent if you watch it um it's just
it's a crazy movie and i had kind of
forgotten all i think mostly what i
remembered about it was obviously the
subject matter which i'll get into in a
minute but i also remembered a lot of
the like really weird like trippy
visuals from it
a lot of which were actually taken from
not real life obviously but were taken
from
source material like stuff that like say
mary shelley talked about in her diaries
and stuff like that about this time
period now i don't want to go too much
into the historical thing because tom
and i did a show
a couple weeks back
uh an episode about mary shelley and
about this
this event that was kind of like the
impetus for her creating frankenstein as
well as like some other things but if
you didn't watch that or you somehow
don't know about this it's a pretty
famous story
uh but what happened was it was back in
1816 it was uh summer but 1816 is very
famously called the year without a
summer because there had been a volcano
eruption and it had kind of essentially
like blocked the sun out and so all the
weather was really bad so it didn't
really get warm it was like really cold
and rainy and the weather was shitty for
like a year
so what ends up happening is that lord
byron the very famous lord byron uh he
was actually in exile and he was living
at this place uh in called uh villa
diodati
in geneva
and um
he like so he was living there kind of
in exile
and he was friends with percy shelley
and mary godwin they weren't actually
married yet and so the two of them along
with mary shelley's half-sister claire
claremont who was having an affair with
lord byron at the time uh came to visit
also in attendance was dr john polidori
who was
byron's uh you know personal physician
and john polidori would actually end up
writing the vampire which may have been
one of the inspirations for bram
stoker's dracula so like i said and mary
shelley obviously were frankenstein and
the whole thing that happened was they
were because of the shitty weather
outside they were all kind of trapped
inside the house for you know days at a
time uh maybe taking a bunch of laudanum
you know opium type stuff no one's
entirely sure but it could be you know
maybe there was some orgy kind of stuff
going on there certainly is in this
movie but um i'm not sure how like
realistic that is they were kind of all
into free love and everything so could
have been so there was a lot of that
kind of stuff going on and uh one night
they all started reading ghost stories
to one another uh from this book that
byron had called phantasmagoriana
which was like a translation into
english from german so it was german
ghost stories and they started reading
it and maybe because of you know
whatever because it's like cabin fever
because they were drugged up or drunk or
whatever they kind of like started
things started getting weird and then
after a while they decided hey let's
have a contest
to
write all our own ghost stories we'll
see like we'll see if we can scare each
other whatever so they all did kind of
start writing stuff like i said john
polidori
ended up writing the vampire which he
may or may not have ripped off from what
lord byron wrote because lord byron he
didn't really write
a whole thing he kind of wrote it was
like a short story like a fragment
and it's about a vampire
uh which might have been the first
appearance of the vampire in english
literature uh or at least the one that's
known but john polidori later took that
concept and fleshed and essentially made
like a novel or like a penny dreadful
out of it and uh he based the character
of lord ruthman on byron everyone's
pretty sure
so there was that whole thing and uh
percy shelley just wrote kind of a
half-assed like poem thing claire didn't
write anything i don't think because she
wasn't really a writer she was just
there because she was sleeping with lord
byron and uh also possibly sleeping with
shelly uh percy shelley and mary shelley
too because there was that whole
threesome situation going on there uh so
there was that and then but mary shelley
ended up writing what would later become
frankenstein based on a horrible
nightmare that she had
while she was staying at the place so if
you know anything about frankenstein
about gothic literature anything like
that i mean the story will be very
familiar to you and interestingly uh you
know it's this has always been a really
interesting story to me too and
apparently it's uh also very interesting
to filmmakers because
uh there was not only this movie like i
said this uh the ken russell gothic came
out in 1986 there was also a movie
called haunted summer
that came out in 1988
and i can't remember who was in i think
that uh alice kriege uh whatever like
from ghost story and stuff i think she
was in that and i remember that one
being okay but it was kind of a more
straightforward like retelling of what
happened whereas this one
is kind of more like a weird
phantasmagoria
of insanity
so it's like this movie it's not so if
you're if you want something that's like
historically accurate probably haunted
summer is closer and i think there was a
spanish language film as well
and uh i believe there was a mary
shelley film that came out like in the
2000s
with l fanning in it and uh that kind of
huge closure of the truth this one is
kind of more like ken russell took the
germ of what actually happened there and
some of the stuff in it is very accurate
like according to you know their diaries
at the time like you know what mary
shelley said happened like during this
uh these few days
but
then some of the stuff is just like
speculation some of this stuff is just
like weird psychedelic stuff that he
just put in there to be freaky or to
like to outrage people like i said
there's a lot of uh so the movie is
pretty much just this one long cavalcade
of
drug use and orgies and madness and
crazy
trippy imagery
which you know like i said may or may
not be
what actually happened so essentially
now this has a massively awesome cast i
have to say
so gabriel byrne
plays lord byron
and he's kind of like the least
uh hysterical of all these i guess mary
shelley's pretty like chill too but he
plays him as essentially i'm not gonna
say like literally as the devil but he
plays him as
the very definition of you know the
famous quote about lord byron mad bad
and dangerous to know he just plays him
as this heartless cruel
[ __ ]
who just doesn't give a [ __ ] about
anybody and you know so he plays him
very much like that so he plays him kind
of like an evil character but still
compelling you know what i mean so he's
actually really good in this uh julian
sands plays percy shelley and uh he just
basically man whatever scenery is in
this movie like julian sands just choose
the [ __ ] out of it holy crap he's just
i have totally forgotten that i love
julian say i love you julian's hands um
you know i actually see he was great in
warlock he was an arachnophobia i love
julian sands but in this movie and i'm
guessing it was because this is ken
russell's thing or whatever he's
basically like you just have to be the
most
holy crap oh my god i can't even like
describe like how over the top like
hysterical uh julian sans is in this
like playing percy shelley he's just
constantly running around crying
jibbering about whatever like he's
running around naked on the roof like
trying to get hit by lightning it's just
the crazy it's a crazy kind of [ __ ] he's
just you know just pontificating about
whatever he's his eyes are always really
big and he's always like
he's always like that it's like it's
hilarious
so there's that uh and then natasha
richardson and i believe this was her
first
movie which is crazy because i had
thought she was in movies before 1986
but i guess not i guess this was like
her first film role she plays mary
shelley she's probably like um
the best
actor in it i guess just because she's
the one that comes across as
the calmest or
you know the one that's not over the top
hysterical like at all times i guess
like in comparison to julian sands who
just seems like he's like two minutes
from like flying off into absolute
insanity or like a big crying jag or
something like every five seconds so she
seems like very very calm in comparison
uh then you also have miriam seer
who plays claire claremont and she kind
of plays her as like this real [ __ ]
almost ch i don't want to say childlike
but she's just very let's play hide and
seek and then she's like running around
the the castle like laughing and you
know rolling around with her boobies
hanging out and she has those big crazy
eyes like the whites of her eyes are
like really really big and she has like
almost big weird like goggle eyes she's
like a little bit freaky looking yeah
and uh the wonderful wonderful timothy
spall playing dr polidori now timothy
spall i had known him like from all
those old like mike lee movies from back
in the 70s and 80s uh most people will
probably recognize him as wormtail from
the harry potter movies
but he's in this and ma and he plays
polidori i'm not sure like i said how
accurate this is it's possible it's
accurate but he plays polidori as very
much
a closeted or you know a gay guy who is
because he's religious he's afraid that
god's gonna punish him for being gay um
but he is totally totally into lord
byron and doesn't like make any uh bones
about it and he's also there's one scene
where they're all kind of like talking
in front of the fire reading ghost
stories and john polidori just straight
up comes up and he just like goes over
his shoulder and like sticks his hand in
like percy shelley's shirt and starts
like rubbing his nipples and stuff so
it's like that's the kind of movie this
is um there's just all kinds of stuff
going on and there's one point too where
he's kind of wearing this thing that
looks like
i guess it's like a white shirt like a
night shirt but then it almost looks
like he has like a white corset
underneath but there's like nothing
underneath it and he's doing this weird
thing where he's like whacking his hand
like in his nail on the wall like almost
like self-crucifixion type of situation
and it's like uh so he comes across as
like very fop-ish and i think lord byron
even calls him that and like uh you know
kind of gets on his case for being gay
for him and whatever so he's he's great
in this too but like i said don't don't
go into this movie i mean if you know
anything about ken russell movies i
don't think any the tone of this will
shock you or anything but
don't go into this expecting some kind
of like historically accurate like you
know these writers are doing this and
no it's not like that everybody is just
like a running screeching drug addicted
hallucinating
mess and it's just like there's orgies
they're all you know there's boobies
there's blood there's all of this kind
of crazy [ __ ] going on and it's just
that i had like i said i had forgotten
how
batshit and how like manic the tone of
this movie was like with all the running
around
so what ends up happening and like i
said a lot of the stuff in this and it's
not i don't even want to say there's
there's not really a plot per se
because it's kind of just like a
vignette
of you know all these people
were at this house which did happen but
and they do do the ghost story thing and
then it goes on from there but it's
basically just
going from one
hallucinatory
uh sort of incident to the next where
it's almost kind of like there's not
so much of connecting the connecting
thing
is that what they do after they read the
ghost stories and everyone starts
getting freaked out everyone's just like
chugging lawd in them like it's going
out of style
and uh so they're all getting a little
bit
uh you know everyone's getting a little
weird
you know nipples are rubbed things are
happening and uh so so they do the ghost
stories everyone's creeped out and then
they have this thing like lord byron
says hey i found this
skull
that's what does i guess like the
gardener like dug it up
uh you know
and found it and it was like hey here i
found a skull you want it and he's like
yeah sure so it's supposed to be like
the black monk or whatever and uh so
he's like so let's have like a seance
with this skull
and so they do that and then claire has
kind of like a
she like flips out and has some kind of
weird psychic vision and then has like a
seizure
at which point like mary tells dr paula
dory ladies yeah she has this kind of
stuff all the time like she has psychic
visions and they come true and uh she
has these kind of like fits
and everything so she's kind of out of
commission for a little while but after
that happens the hallucinations really
start to like [ __ ] ramp up man and
they seem to be i mean mary see starts
seeing like a figure outside of her
window they all start seeing like a
figure like a monster kind of like percy
starts seeing
like he like he goes out to the barn and
he kind of sees this monster like this
hulking sort of thing like out in the
barn but he keeps seeing like this gross
like spooge kind of like some kind of
like weird
liquid um like puddles of it's not blood
it's kind of like i don't know it's like
some goopy kind of with siemens kind of
stuff
and but lumpy and he keeps because his
big thing and this is actually true uh
this is from mary shelley's actual
diaries that percy shelley had a horror
like one of his greatest fears was being
buried alive which like i said that's
that's a pretty legit um horror because
that would be uh
probably one of the worst things that
could happen to you but so he was really
really paranoid about being buried alive
and so he has a lot of kind of visions
about that and they do uh the thing and
this actually was uh also something that
mary shelley mentioned in her diary
about this time period was that they had
been reading um that poem christabel
and
percy like flipped out like and screamed
and ran out of the room so i guess this
isn't as this movie's not as
historically inaccurate
as it seems because percy was screaming
and running out of the room a lot like a
big giant drama queen all the time which
he does a lot in this movie so like i
said
uh but he had had he said he'd had a
vision of a woman that had
eyes instead of nipples and so they do
that in this movie too but like actually
he goes like claire goes missing like
they hear her laughing like around the
house or whatever but they can't find
her and then percy comes across her and
she's kind of like hey big boy whatever
and like takes her shirt off and then
her boobs look normal for a second but
then she like
she does those like weird goggle eyes at
him and she's like look into my eyes and
then he looks down and like you know
they have like she has eyes instead of
nipples and then of course he flips out
about that uh mary shelley starts seeing
like a lot of snakes there's a lot of
boa constrictors in this and she's also
having visions of her children dying
like her baby dying which actually did
happen like i said if you we just did a
show about this whole thing uh just a
couple weeks back and uh yeah mary
shelley lost a lot of her children a lot
of them died i think only one survived
into adulthood so uh she was very
traumatized by uh some of the babies
died when they were like baby babies and
some of them died when they were like
five you know from illnesses and stuff
so it was uh she had a lot of loss and
sorrow in her life a lot of her children
dying and um you know some people have
speculated and i kind of feel like that
maybe is one thing one criticism that i
could level at this movie was that it it
basically kind of straight up says that
mary shelley wrote frankenstein
because she wanted to bring her dead
children back to life which may or may
not be true to an extent but it does
seem like a little glib and reductive to
just kind of like say that that was the
motivating force because there was a lot
of other [ __ ] going on in her life too
uh which like i said i went into
on the show like she you know grew up in
kind of like a scientific like the
enlightenment and everything and she was
fascinated by
uh you know galvanism and all this kind
of stuff that was going with electricity
and stuff like that at the time uh you
know and and grave robbing and that kind
of stuff um so so i don't know
if that was her only motivation but it
does kind of go into that and so she has
a lot of like really creepy visions of
like she has visions of her
you know having like a having a dead
baby and then you know she has a lot of
dead baby kind of visions so there's all
that kind of stuff going on so everybody
it's almost kind of like um and then
claire's big fear is rats and then at
one point they find her and she's down
in the dungeon or crypt or whatever the
[ __ ]
that everybody has that in their house
you know just like in the in the lower
regions it just all looks like this big
[ __ ] basement dungeon down there so
they find her down there and she's like
naked and all muddy and she's got like a
rat in her mouth so basically what like
what happens in this is that after they
have the seance all of their fears
coalesce
into
a creature pretty much so it's almost
kind of like making a meta commentary
about the all of these writers and you
know particularly mary shelley who made
a creation like in the sense of the book
but also dr frankenstein making the
creation but there but he's kind of like
making a little bit of a meta statement
or like a little sly in joke or
something like that about all of these
writers getting together
and making a monster that's comprised of
all their worst fears so
that happened so like the bulk of the
movie is just them running around
experiencing scary [ __ ] like that's
their own fears kind of like coming back
but it's usually like kind of like a
lumbering monster but you don't really
see it
and uh you know we're eating rats or
seeing snakes or whatever so it was that
kind of stuff
you know i think and lord byron has a
thing with leeches and polidori like
puts a bunch of leeches in his food and
even drinks a thing with leeches in it
at one point now that i'm thinking about
it it's a pretty gross ass movie it's a
lot of growth it's a lot of fluids
and uh you know snakes and leeches and
that kind of [ __ ] but yes there's all
that kind of stuff going on and uh so
yeah but so after they
kind of have come to the conclusion
that they have
made a creation
out like they've sort of
summoned it from the ether because all
their fears are so uh prevalent that
they've made a creature out of it
they've like brought it to life
so then
so after that they kind of decide well
we have to like we we have to have
another seance because only since we
conjured it with our minds then our
minds is the only way we can get rid of
it
so then that kind of like has to happen
this is a really really weird movie and
i kind of feel like and it's weirder
than i remember i remembered it being
weird because i remembered like all the
um all the like creepy like crazy
imagery and stuff like the eye boobs and
uh and all that kind of [ __ ] but i had
forgotten
like i said how
over the top like this kind of
hysteria that sort of permeates it i had
forgotten about that and i had also
forgotten that for the large part of it
it's just this one night where
everyone's basically just like tripping
out like everyone's just on a really bad
trip
and then it ends and you know what i
mean and then like the end of it is just
like the next morning everyone's fine
seemingly oh have some tea yeah that's
just how it goes like the nights here at
villa diode you'll get used to it
you know everything's fine the next day
no ghosts in the daylight says lord
byron berry shell and she's like i
suppose so and then basically it fades
out and then it kind of goes to the
present day or you know
the contemporary like 1986 and then they
have like a tour boat going by because
at one point like one of the last things
that mary sees in her hallucinations is
she sees a vision of everyone's future
and if you know anything like i said
about the biographies of these actual
people she sees what actually happens to
them like she sees percy drowning and
then her and byron like burning his body
on the beach
um she sees claire
what does she see how did claire die i
can't even remember how claire died i
just remembered she kind of went off oh
she sees a vision of byron with uh him
and claire's daughter allegra
uh like putting a leg in a coffin
because allegra did die when she was
five uh as far as i recall so she sees
visions of the future so that like kind
of bummed her out but that was like it
was really weird because that's kind of
like all that [ __ ] happened and then
like the next day everything was fine
again like nobody said like did [ __ ] man
did that even happen or was it
nightmares or whatever but so i don't
know it was just really weird but then
so like the last scene is a modern-day
tour group
and it's kind of going by villa diodati
and it's telling about what happened to
everybody how lord byron ended up dying
like a couple years after this and percy
died and you know mary and claire were
the only ones that were kind of left
alive and john polidori like killed
himself which
she also saw a vision of i thought that
was a little weird like i guess i guess
he had that in there
for the benefit of people who
wouldn't get that mary was seeing
visions of the future because it's like
like i knew because i knew what happened
to percy shelly and i knew what happened
to john polidori and stuff because i'm
into this incident so i kind of knew a
lot about it so they had kind of had
that little thing tagged on the end
where there's kind of like yeah this
this tour guide is just saying and then
lord byron died of this and that and
percy shelley drowned and stuff so so i
guess so audiences would be like oh i
get it so she was seeing the future and
you know where this monster this monster
that we created from our fear is going
to stalk us like until we're dead and
stuff like that which was kind of like
the whole thing so yeah this movie is on
to be at the moment if you're into
you know frankenstein mary shelley any
of that kind of stuff i would recommend
seeing it but like i said it's ken
russell so it's really weird and i do
kind of feel like
this is
probably it's i mean obviously it's not
his best work but
this is what is the one that came out
before lair the white worm lara the
white worm i feel like had even more of
like a black comedy kind of vibe to it
and it had a little bit of the same kind
of tone as this i think a lot of the
stuff that he did in the mid 80s had
this i feel like he didn't make a lot of
movies after this he made [ __ ] i think
wasn't theresa russell in that which i
remember liking but i haven't seen that
for a long time and then he made one or
two that i did that i haven't seen
but this is it's just a very
it's kind of silly and it's kind of it's
like way way over the top especially
julian sands he is like super super over
the top but
it seems deliberate you know what i mean
it's not like oh everyone's just bad
action because obviously these are all
like really good actors so i kind of
feel like that was a choice that they
all made it's like let's just make this
as over-the-top hysterical as we can
like i said gabriel byrne is pretty
chill as lord byron natasha richardson
is pretty chill as mary shelley but
julian sands and uh you know the chick
that plays uh claire claremont
and uh two and timothy spall as well
they just ham it the [ __ ] up i mean
big time so you know what i mean so and
and like i said the whole the bulk of
the movie it's about an hour and 45
minutes or whatever it is the bulk of
the movie is them just like running
around screaming and seeing [ __ ] up
[ __ ] like for
most of the run time of the movie like
once they do the seance
so just know that going it's not like
it's not plot heavy it's uh but it's an
interesting
cultural curio and uh it's an
interesting ken russell film it's not my
favorite but
i don't know i still kind of love it
anyway even though it's just it's kind
of ridiculous but it's kind of
ridiculous in an awesome sort of way um
but this is definitely not
a standard like historical
you know a very stayed historical and
this is what happened like when they
were all at the villa diode all these
all these romantics and stuff these
writers it's it's it's crazy like i said
there's orgies and drugs and
bloodletting and just all kind of crazy
[ __ ] but yeah so it's super trippy um so
yeah if you haven't seen it it's on to
be for free
um so go watch it also uh gotta give a
shout out i really like that they put
the henry fuselli painting the nightmare
in there probably one of my favorite
paintings ever
and uh so i like that they and they kind
of used a version of that with natasha
richardson laying down with like a
little imp boy like sitting on her chest
like for uh the you know the poster you
know and the cover the vhs and
everything so i kind of like that and
they actually put the actual
you know painting or obviously not the
actual painting because i think that's
in london but they put you know a copy
of the painting in the movie so i
thought that was kind of neat too uh
kind of tied the
i tied the whole thing together just
like just like the dude's wrong but yeah
so uh
it's on to me go watch it tell me if
you've seen it tell me what you think of
it um because i'm really really curious
about this one i've been wanting to do
this one for a while because like i said
i haven't seen it for years and uh and i
remembered seeing it a bunch of times
back in the day because i used to have
it on vhs uh but yeah so i so i had
forgotten like how ridiculous it was but
i still kind of love it so yeah so uh
that'll do it for this flickers of fear
i will see you guys on the next one bye